now Republican Congressman Mike
gallegrated Wisconsin sir good morning
thank you for your time here what do you
make of this and
how strong do you think the card that
you're playing could be
well I think particularly as the
American people see the complete
lawlessness at the southern border and
the way in which it affects not only
border states border districts but
districts like mine I'm way up there in
Wisconsin when we talk about the Border
we're usually talking about Canada but
we have crime directly related to
lawlessness at the southern border
that's claimed lives in my district we
have massive problems with fentanyl
that's killing people in my district so
I think we are on the right side of this
issue it's just common sense we have to
have operational control of our Southern
border and the fact that we don't the
fact that this Administration has
embraced an open borders policy and in
many cases has turned a blind eye to
Common Sense positions like Romania
Mexico using physical infrastructure
like a border wall I think the American
people just see the chaos that's
creating the human tragedy that's
getting so we have to stand strong
securing the border is the right thing
to do for the defense of our country for
the well being of our citizens and at
the same time we need to send a message
to people that want to come here legally
that that's the right way to do it not
incentivize people coming here illegally
so in a negotiation like this you
wouldn't get everything that you want
but what specifically with the
Republicans demand be in a bill if they
were to vote for the government funding
I think we're made in Mexico policy is
on that list I think more funding for
the border wall is on that list maybe we
can insert into that list that members
of the bind Administration just start
telling the truth about the border right
the best president the vice president
was on TV the other day saying despite
the fact that we've had two million
people come here illegally in this
fiscal year alone including 78 suspected
terrorists that the border is secure
just be honest with the American people
so part of the strategy here is just to
force an honest discussion about the
problem that we're facing at the
southern border as well as highlight
some of the more radical positions that
the Democratic party has right now
there's still a faction that wants to
defund ice and that is a crazy crazy
position to have I wanted to get your
comment on another topic here this is a
big deal overseas you know what's
happening in Putin in Russia and Ukraine
Etc uh John Kirby was with us yesterday
on our set here in New York and we asked
them the question that seems to be
rather apparent and that is this watch
are we effectively at war with Russia no
we are not no not at all Russia is at
War inside Ukraine and despite the
rhetoric we heard from Putin last night
trying once again to make this about the
West versus Russia or the United States
versus Russia or NATO versus Russia
nothing could be farther from the truth
so when you woke up yesterday and you
heard about the threat about nuclear
weapons on behalf of Vladimir Putin what
did you think as a member of the
military yourself
well I think Putin is obviously trying
to Blackmail us he's trying to
intimidate the west and I think the
president missed a massive opportunity
to clearly signal that if Putin were to
take this step this massive escalatory
step that NATO would respond very
forcefully and I think sending that
clear signal actually gives us the best
chance of deterring nuclear escalation
time and time again this Administration
talks itself out of taking the steps
necessary to give the ukrainians what
they need to win right now they're
delaying the provision of certain weapon
systems the atacums are at the top of
the list because they fear that this
will be provocative but it's the fear of
provocation that I think is actually
causing Putin to go further and further
so I was very disappointed that the
president didn't take advantage of the
Forum he had at the U.N and of course
Putin is actually fighting two Wars
right now there's the war on the ground
in Ukraine and then there's the broader
commodity War where he's leveraging
energy weapons against Europe he's
trying to control the Black Sea in order
to control the grain trade that's going
to escalate going forward and that's
where we need a coherent energy policy
which this Administration does not have
the president doubled down on his
climate change agenda which isn't
working for Americans at his U.N speech
and that was very disappointing to see
Congressman Mike Gallagher thank you for
being with us this morning kicking us
off on a Thursday appreciate it hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now